it's been over four years since apple  walked out on stage and revealed the  original airpods and they want to change  the world of wireless audio forever  again let me explain the vice president  of acoustics at apple said that they  want more bandwidth than bluetooth can  offer with the main incentive being that  apple can enable lossless audio support  which minchiko already said is coming  this year with the airpods pro 2. and  the only realistic option is going to be  ultra wideband because uwb actually uses  less power than bluetooth while also  having lower latency further effective  range and much higher bandwidth and  seeing as apple has been packing their  most popular devices with the u1 chip  the infrastructure is already set in  stone and ready for apple to make the  switch by releasing air pods with the u1  chip built in so in reality all of the  puzzle pieces line up together perfectly